hi I'm Zach Galifianakis I love
self-promotion wait what's the other
part I have Zach Galifianakis and I'm
gonna go undercover on the Internet
[Music]
Korra
never heard of you what are some
interesting facts about Zach
Galifianakis
well I'm right-handed on camera looks
shorter than I actually have it with
real life I'm six-two I used to play for
the Washington Generals I have fester
psoriasis
unfortunately only one of those is true
it was the last one submit how did Funny
or Die get President Obama to interview
with between two ferns I met with
Valerie Jarrett and I had a plan and I
pulled her specifically why I thought it
would work and she thought about it and
then they called and said let's do it
and I kind of told her the reason if I'm
an idiot it only makes everything else
look better
Wikipedia early work he began acting on
television guest-starring in Boston
Common and joined Saturday Night Live as
writer but only lasted two weeks I
worked on Saturday Night Live for two
weeks and Britney Spears was the host
one week when I was doing it wrote a
sketch Will Ferrell was gonna play a
bodyguard to her bellybutton and we were
gonna shrink wheel down to fit into a
belly button she just stared at me after
I explained it to her and then she goes
yeah that's funny
posted these are my trademarks I didn't
know I had trademarks I have a birthmark
in the shape of india.arie I can't
believe I'm still trying to do that joke
he has a thick bushy beard yes it's a
very awkward humor yeah sure I think
anything in the talk word is funny
because it's not supposed to be that way
and we all try to carry ourselves as
cool them stuff so I like when people
are not cool because it's funny often
plays strange socially awkward
characters
I think that's all I've ever played it
should say he can only play strange
socially awkward characters and messy
hair I'm messy hair only because I have
a lot of body and head lice and I'm
always doing inventory they also have
halitosis I don't have halitosis I don't
have halitosis that's another one of my
trademarks I don't have it is that
claustrophobic yes I am claustrophobic
but not as much as I used to be I used
to not write elevators like an elevator
submitted more coral what is that gala
the neck is best known for my Super Bowl
wins next reddit how do you observe us
right there material I feel like I can't
imagine second I could sit down writing
jokes I really like absurdism and comedy
and feel like it's my strong suit you
told me a lot about yourself I do write
jokes down I don't sit down to write
them it happens throughout the day that
I'll just think of something or actually
in conversation and then I will jot it
down
absurdism is a little different when you
doing stand-up because a lot of people
talk about their life on stage and I
don't really want to talk about real
things on stage I would rather just do
absurd his jokes but sometimes that is a
challenge when you do in standing
because a lot of people are not used to
absurdism in a stand-up format but I
mean it is very very possible to do it
and to do it kind of okay
or Quora what are the best between two
ferns was that gout for next episodes I
did one with Charlize Theron through
fahren what I liked about that one she
just showed up by herself with a pack of
cigarettes she didn't have any people
with her she didn't have any makeup on
and we shot it in a garage and she was
just the coolest person so I like that
one because of the way she was as a
person just without you know and then I
did one with the president that I liked
a lot to President Obama Twitter
the devil it's actually me do actors
remember every role they play seems
unlikely does a coffin actress
being and frenemy I didn't know that was
the name of the movie you changed it
I remember this movie it's probably one
that you can skip movie wise maybe this
sounds interesting to you I would skip
that one I don't know if I saw it boom
will we see baskets season four anytime
soon she says I miss it so much
yes we're filming it now and it should
be out in the summer I think even more
Cora what are that Galifianakis as
strengths as a comedian I know how to
hold a microphone I can sometimes
isolate the audience good there's 500
people in the audience sometimes I'm
good at making just two people laugh
that's one of my strong suits sorry I
almost fell asleep
how did Will Ferrell check out the
Bacchus get along well filming the
campaign wonderfully he's a very sweet
man
you too what's the best way to reach you
email oh my god the shade thrown in this
interview was amazingly brazen I can't
believe her PR team allowed a release to
be signed unless they edited some of the
curse word I'm not going to say it cuz
this is the Internet he said in later
during post-production okay so with the
between two ferns interviews if people
are not going to let us do what we
usually do that we're not gonna do it so
we told them if you don't want these
questions that we don't have to do the
interview I'm not gonna change the show
because someone doesn't want to do that
but she was really cool about it the
funny thing about this interview we had
to edit out the best part of it because
it was too long hopefully I'll release
that one because it's really funny or
Quora
for someone who appears to have natural
course and truly what products and
treatments do you think that galloping
is useless because it's so soft and
silky looking do we wrote this I want to
thank this person because this is
actually a beauty question I never get
this and thank you cuz I spend a lot of
time grooming I bathed with this thing
called Bronner's I think it's called dr.
Bronner's
it's good for shampoo in here and
sometimes they use my kid shampoo baby
shampoo there like the way it smells
the silky silky part sometimes internet
Oh what I'll do I don't do anything I
just wash my hair with baby shampoo it
if the hangover is remade into Bollywood
then which actress will play in winter
rolls I would love to be in a Bollywood
so I hope they'll ask me to do it I
don't know who would play me in the
Bollywood world but I'm sure there is a
version that they could find what is the
best zach galifianakis movie avatar
more ready between two ferns was that
golf and I'm just moving the works of
Netflix yes how's it going to be a movie
though I don't know it's just gonna be a
movie you just learn nothing about me
for real and thanks Internet enjoy
yelling at each other